i remember i watched the uh i watched
the live stream of the new genshin
announcement for like the 2.0 in azuba
where they announced the new area and i
think it was getting like almost 400 000
people 400 000 people on twitch on
twitch not youtube twitch live
concurrent which is like how much does
like press conferences on on like ea or
like press conferences e3 and stuff get
it's not that much like 100 100k max
yeah it gets like 100k 200k maybe like
this again shin update
stream was getting 400k viewers
concurrent on twitch which might be the
[ __ ] is going on which mind you or a lot
of the stuff that they announced had
already been leaked
as well so it's like people were like
tuning in to like look at lead ship i
mean like it's confirmed i guess yeah i
mean i i i'm sure if i was a fan i would
get behind the hyphen oh yeah i'd be
very happy for it but i don't have to
really play aside i mean yeah i mean you
know obviously it did very well for them
right yeah but yeah it just blew me away
because like i was like oh there's a
game stream happening yeah 400 000
people
sitting there waiting for a [ __ ]
update like are you serious and now
more gotcha
yes
more waifus
yeah i mean like i haven't haven't
gotten back into genji and i've been
thinking about it because of a new area
but you know even even like out of the
three of us the person who was most of
the inter genji was probably me and now
she's like that's this is a lot of
people watching an anime anime waifu
game right now could you imagine if like
[ __ ] like if like fake grand order
had an update and there was four hundred
thousand people like watching i don't
know
don't don't do that to me
don't give me hope
is genji in like is is it not sorry is
it majoritively played on mobile or pc
i'm assuming pc i think i'm not actually
i don't know i must say because honestly
this is a complete assumption yeah we
don't know right half the people i know
that play genshin half of them play on
mobile oh wait what i thought
like all of my japanese friends would
play games and play on mobile oh god i
thought it would be more majority pc i
mean well i think so right yeah because
i i i did not have a fun time playing
genshin on mobile
um at all i think i think some people
just played on both like when they're
home they're playing on pc but sometimes
you know they've got to get on that
grind while on the go well i think i
think that's
one of like the biggest advantages that
gentian has over like a lot of aaa games
which is the fact that it's so [ __ ]
easy to play yeah you know you you
literally like every account is linked
and now you can like even link your ps4
account to like every other account so
it's just it just makes it like
ridiculous is it on the switch as well
it's not yeah
[Laughter]
this is the problem when i'm a fan of uh
a lot of things i also end up promoting
unfortunately i've fully disconnected
myself from gaming hype i don't get
hyped about games anymore i don't know
if that means no happiness for me but
i've i've just stopped getting hyped and
i've stopped watching announcements i
think i just stopped getting hyped about
things in general because i've just
because like
that's a little stressful it's like it's
called pessimism yeah literally because
i've ran into so many situations where i
just get hyped and i either experience
hype fatigue or
fatigue
so i had to experience height fatigue or
i just end up getting disappointed with
the final result right and i'm just like
oh well then what the [ __ ] you know give
me back my hype all right yeah so now
let's give me back my opinion
i want a refund i want to refund all my
hype please still waiting for my
cyberpunk hype refund